heute versucht hat in berlin von a nach
b zu kommen dass der hat unter umständen
ziemlich große probleme denn er wurde
ordentlich ausgebremst und das lag an
diesen traktoren hier die zogen forst
brandenburger tor und blockierten den
verkehr in der gesamten stadt die
veranstalter sprechen von 40.000
teilnehmern und 5600 treckern
das ist weit mehr als die ursprünglich
erwartet hatten
veranstaltet wurde das ganze aber nicht
von den großen bauernverbänden die das
normalerweise tun sondern von einem
netzwerk das nennt sich landschaft
verbindung und die eint dass sie den
agrar packt das agrar paket der
bundesregierung gerade beschlossenen
gesammelt ablehnen und man konnte auch
heute auf der demo hören dass die bauern
ziemlich sauer auf die politik sind das
finden wir sehr unfair dass wir
mittlerweile die prügelknaben der nation
geworden sind und deshalb sind wir hier
wir vor deren antwort an die politik
denkt und sie werden in ordnung man
sagen wieder ein bisschen zurück traum
meine gesprächspartnerin heute war aber
nicht da sie ist im münsterland
geblieben ist uns jetzt im kuhstall
zugeschaltet eine kallas ist gelernte
landwirtin und bloggt unter erklärbar de
über landwirtschaft und klärt auf halo
annika du hast gerade die beiden
meinungen gehört einmal wir wollen nicht
mehr die prügelknaben der nation sein
und wir wollen dass die regulierungen
zurückgeschraubt werden sind das
meinungen denen du dich auch anschließt
also meinung eins kann ich gut
nachvollziehen
prügelknaben der nation das wird
wahrscheinlich so empfunden weil viele
einfach nur schlecht schlechte presse
über sich wahrnehmen weil das einfach
auch die presse ist die am meisten durch
kommt deswegen kann ich die aussage ganz
gut nachvollziehen
punkt zwei ist so ein bisschen
2schneidig zu betrachten nur verbote
ablehnen geht auch nicht aber man muss
einfach mehr miteinander sprechen und
das ist glaube ich auch die forderung
die dahintersteckt
wir gucken uns jetzt gleich mal an was
du alles noch so an meinungen hast und
was du an vorschlägen hat aber jetzt
schauen wir uns ganz kurz mal anders die
bundesregierung eigentlich beschlossen
hat in sachen agrar paket das hat max
stöhr für uns zusammengefasst
das agrar paket der bundesregierung
besteht aus drei maßnahmen ein tier wohl
kennzeichen soll kommen die eu-gelder
für landwirte sollen umverteilt und
insekten besser geschützt werden
erstens das tierwohl kennzeichen für
schweine
es ist ein freiwilliges label und soll
zeigen welche betriebe die gesetzlichen
mindeststandards bei aufzucht haltung
und schlachtung übertreffen
zweitens die eu agrarförderung landwirte
erhalten aus dem topf eine basisprämie
von 175 euro pro hektar land das sie
bewirtschaften diese direktzahlungen
machen durchschnittlich 40 prozent ihres
einkommens aus habe 2020 sinkt diese
basisprämie dafür erhalten land würde
aber mehr geld wenn sie sich strenger an
umwelt und klima vorschriften halten
mehr geld soll auch für förderprogramme
bereitgestellt werden zum beispiel um
vögel besser zu schützen die auf wiesen
brüten
drittens der insektenschutz den will die
bundesregierung vor allem durch weniger
pflanzenschutzmitteln auf den feldern
verbessern
das umstrittene glyphosat soll ab
kommenden jahr stark eingeschränkt ab
2023 dann ganz verboten werden
die eu fordert zudem zu nachbesserungen
bei der düngeverordnung auf die nutzung
von gülle und weiteren düngemitteln soll
daher künftig reduziert werden vor allem
um die nitratbelastung im grundwasser zu
verringern
weniger dünger heißt im zweifel aber
auch weniger ertrag für die landwirte
und darum gab es heute in berlin mächtig
ärger eine kallas ist gelernte
landwirtin ist mir in münster im
kuhstall zugeschaltet douglas unter
erklärbaren de über landwirtschaft auf
auch auf instagram bist du ja ziemlich
aktiv wie stehst du denn zu diesem agrar
paket was hast du da den followern und
lesern erklärt er genauso wieder ein
spieler ist das agrar paket einfach ein
riesen ding also man kann das jetzt
nicht in zwei drei worten bewerten oder
einschätzen wie kläre ich dazu auf also
letztendlich sprechen wir bei
erklärbarer gar nicht wirklich über die
einzelnen forderungen im ersten sondern
wir finden
erstmal muss die basis geschaffen werden
auf der überhaupt diskutiert werden kann
weil das ist fachlich sehr sehr weit
oben um genau darüber zu diskutieren und
das zu bewerten
und wir wollen mit dem erklärbar eine
basis schaffen also ich möchte aufklären
wie landwirtschaft eigentlich wirklich
aktuell tickt um auf dem aktuellen stand
basierend dann über das agrar paket
diskutieren zu können
aber wenn ich mir das jetzt mal mit
meinem laienhaften journalistischen
wissen angucke weniger dünger weniger
insektizide zum schluss zum schutz der
der umwelt und mehr subventionen für
leute die nachhaltig wirtschaften das
klingt jetzt für mich erstmal nach einer
guten sache
das ist glaube ich dir das ist nach
einer guten sache klingt aber
letztendlich sind die landwirte die
praktiker die das umsetzen müssen
und so rosig das auf dem ersten
augenblick aussieht und letztendlich
wollen wir auch alle genau dasselbe wir
landwirte wollen den sekten schutz
die landwirte wollen die umwelt schützen
und wir arbeiten schließlich in und mit
der natur das heißt sie ist das größte
gut was wir zu schützen haben aber auf
der anderen seite ist immer die
herleitung wie wir dahin kommen ein
großes ding und das wird auf der einen
seite theoretisch beschlossen aber die
praktiker müssen das ausführen der
grundsatz den empfinde ich ziemlich
gleich letztendlich wollen weiter an
einem strang ziehen
aber die wege dahin sind ziemlich
unterschiedlich und da ist auch genau
der punkt das klingt auf der einen seite
rosig aber um da wirklich auch auf einer
basis zu diskutieren
die letztendlich praktisch umsetzbar ist
da sind wir lange noch nicht angekommen
und da muss einfach viel mehr
hintergrundwissen
kannst du das mal vielleicht an einem
beispiel erklären wo die schwierigkeit
ist das umzusetzen den wir mal dass mit
dem dünger also bei dem dünger ist es ja
so deutschland hat ziemlich viel hohe
nitratwerte die eu hat schon gesagt das
geht so nicht ihr verstößt gegen unsere
höchstwerte das heißt da drohen saftige
geldstrafen aber deswegen hat die
bundesregierung jetzt beschlossen das
muss weniger gedüngt werden das machen
andere länder dänemark zum beispiel
jetzt auch schon wo ist da das problem
für die landwirte
ja nährstoff oder oder nitrat es hat
halt glaube ich nicht nur rein den punkt
aus der landwirtschaft ist nicht nur die
landwirtschaft ist daran quasi schuld
sondern das ist ein großes ganzes was
man dabei betrachten muss und wenn wir
jetzt das praktische beispiel umsetzung
in der landwirtschaft sehen die
landwirte müssen bedarfsgerecht düngen
das tun sie auch denn sie müssen schon
viele auflagen erfüllen wie die dinge
bedarfsermittlung aktuellen stoffstrom
bilanz erstellen wir sind schon viele
dinge hinzugekommen
wenn wir sind in deutschland bürokratie
land nummer 1 das heißt die halbe schon
sehr viele standards an
wir hatten jetzt allerdings nur zwei
jahre zeit das umzusetzen in der praxis
und da können noch gar nicht die großen
auswirkungen letztendlich zu sehen sein
in den ergebnissen weil wir zwei jahre
umsetzung nicht meine seinen boden der
arbeitet bis man da ein ergebnis bekommt
da sind wir noch nicht angelangt und
jetzt sofort die nächste verschärfung
hinterher zu fordern ist ganz ganz
schwierig weil wir halt im endeffekt
noch kein wirkliches ergebnis haben was
die erste forderung mit sich gebracht
hat oder die erste verschärfung und
letztendlich dann sofort eine zweite
verschärfung auferlegt bekommen ich habe
zwei jahre in der nährstoff beratung
gearbeitet
das heißt ich habe viele verschiedene
betriebe gesehen und auf diesen
betrieben nährstoff vergleiche gerechnet
oder für diese betriebe nährstoff
vergleiche gerechnet und da hat man das
dort nicht gesehen was für ein
riesenaufwand das ist und wie genau das
auch ausgerechnet wird wie die jünger
verteilung auf den betrieb ist also die
tür ausscheidung die dünger verteilung
das ist ja schon alles sehr sehr sehr
gut dokumentiert und sehr streng mit
auflagen unterliegt aber ist denn ich
denke ich sollte man an diesem punkt
auch ist denn bei den bauern tatsächlich
so eine bewusstsein dafür da dass zu
viel gedüngt wurde dass wir nie trat
problemen haben im grundwasser und dass
da jetzt was gemacht werden muss
also was heißt zu viel geduld das kann
ich natürlich nicht beurteilen weil ich
zu den damaligen zeiten noch nicht da
war was wurde vorher nicht wirklich so
genau kontrolliert beziehungsweise genau
berechnet wie das in den letzten jahren
dazu gekommen ist und da kann es schon
sein dass früher zu viel dünnere gaben
erfolgt sind aber definitiv in den
letzten jahren sich da ganz ganz viel
verschärft hat und die landwirte sich
absolut bewusst sind dass sie da wie sie
den dünger einsetzen denn gezielt
einsetzen auch wenn sie den einsätzen
wann kann die pflanze das
zu nehmen wann ist der richtige
zeitpunkt das spielt ja alles mit der 1
da kann man ja nicht einfach nur auf
menge reduzieren und sagen dann bedarf
es nur noch das und das ding und deine
pflanze braucht aber eigentlich noch
viel viel mehr
und da kommen wir dann ja auch zu den
ertragseinbussen wie ist denn die
stimmung unter den bauern die du jetzt
kennst du bist ja viel unterwegs du bist
gut vernetzt mit vielen bauern nehmen
die sich selber war als die armen
schweine der nation und wie
gerechtfertigt findest du dass die armen
schweine der nation also letztendlich
kann ich diesen gedanken nachvollziehen
und ich glaube dass sie sich an mancher
stelle auch definitiv so fühle ich meine
sonst würde würden so viele landwirte
heute nicht auf die straße gegangen oder
gefahren sein
also die die grundstimmung was richtig
angespannt ich stehen mit dem rücken zur
wand und deswegen mussten sie sich auch
auf jeden fall luft verschaffen das hört
man von landschaft verbindung ich hab
mir den organisatoren noch gesprochen
in man jetzt merke ich dass es ist aber
auch so also ich kann das zum beispiel
nicht gut nachvollziehen weil
landwirtschaft gibt mir persönlich ganz
ganz viel also für mich war das eine
super positive entwicklung von meiner
persönlichkeit in die landwirtschaft zu
gehen und jedes mal wenn ich das
mitbekommen dass der landwirtschaftliche
betriebe einfach sagt ich weiß nicht ob
ich weitermache ob mein junior weiter
macht ob es noch eine weitere generation
gibt letztendlich will ich meinen
nachfolgern eigentlich gar nicht
empfehlen weiter zu machen weil das
aktuell so ein sicheres standbein ist
dass ich den er empfehle bildet euch gut
aus und weiteren geht an den vorder
nachgelagerten bereich oder entwickelt
euch woanders hin
was ich persönlich super super schade
finde weil ich ja nicht von einem
betrieb komme und ja so voller herzen in
die landwirtschaft reingegangen bin und
er ist sehr sehr traurig finde das mit
anzusehen dass da einfach mittlerweile
ja eher so ein bisschen negative
emotionen aufkommen was die verbindung
zum beruf angeht her
annika wie guck mal in die kommentare
hier meine kollegen haben schon mal
zusammengefasst und fleißig gesammelt
dann würde ich nicht selber jetzt alles
durchlesen muss zum beispiel schreibt
marco auf youtube es geht nach meiner
meinung den landwirtschaft nicht
schlecht wenn sie die zeichen der zeit
erkennt und danach handelt es habe schon
genügend landwirte den weg eingeschlagen
und das mit erfolg darauf kommen wir
gleich auch noch mal dann schreibt aber
christoph auf twitter wenn alle bio
dann ist alles okay so einfach ist es
nicht etwa sind zuletzt die preise für
bio getreide und biomilch auch
eingebrochen
aber es gibt auch hier ganz klar
menschen die von diesen protesten nichts
halten niklas von haaren auf facebook
das agrar paket ist ein guter anfang
aber immer noch viel zu lasch ein echter
bauer demonstriert gegen das paket weil
es zu lasch ist und die falschen dinge
fördert nicht nach fläche sollte
subventioniert werden sondern nach dem
ökologischen fußabdruck pro quadratmeter
bzw pro tier da spricht niklas ein
problem an dass tatsächlich gibt es das
was wir jetzt auch gelöst werden soll
wenn die subventionen werden vor allem
noch quadratmetern verteilt und nicht
nach der frage wie das land genutzt wird
annika ist das ein richtiger weg dass
man sagt okay wir gucken jetzt auch was
die bauern mit dem land machen und
schmeißt nicht einfach geld und wer die
größte fläche hat kriegt das meiste ab
also man sich über die verteilung
gedanken zu machen finde ich schon
richtig weil wir das wie du das gerade
auch treffen gesagt hast im endeffekt
kriegt er mit den meisten land auch das
meiste geld da sind viele betriebe die
sich im letzten jahren spezialisiert
haben auf die halterungen sind dann
ziemlich aus dem vorder sind dann
relativ schlechter gestellt als die rein
ackerbaubetriebe mit vier flächen
besitzt aber so grundsätzlich also ich
find die kommentare alle richtig gut und
dass es auch so der ansatzpunkt man
sollte miteinander darüber reden und
sollte jedem gesichtspunkt auch
irgendwie
beleuchten und auch durchdenken ich
finde den ansatz des agrar paket ist
auch nicht schlecht dass man
veränderungen muss veränderung braucht
dass das wollen wir landwirte ja auch
also wir sind alle bereit veränderungen
anzutreten aber die frage ist halt wie
diese veränderung nach ergebnis in der
praxis aussehen
und letztendlich ist da der bauer am
ende der das aus für den der praxis das
heißt wie in der theorie können alle
viel bestimmen aber in der praxis muss
das immer noch der betrieb und der
landwirt selber ausführen
die haben gerade schon gehört
veränderungen ist ein thema bio ist ein
thema denn viele bauern oder einige
bauern viele sind das glaube ich noch
nicht sind jetzt einen weg gegangen
haben sich schon für bio landwirtschaft
entschieden haben quasi den ganzen
betrieb umgestellt weil sie so mehr geld
nehmen können für ihre produkte also
auch das überleben gesichert ist wenn
ein kleinerer betrieb ist und dazu noch
was für die umwelt tut aber die frage
ist würde das überhaupt auf allen höfen
in ganz deutschland gehen und da hat
elisabeth schmidt mal einen biobauern
gefragt diese biomass bullen können sich
frei bewegen keine engen boxen
stattdessen dürfen sie auch mal auf die
weide und setzen trotzdem so viel an
dass hendrix stolze sie schlachten und
das fleisch verkaufen kann ist bio in
deutschland massentauglich ende stolze
sagt ja ich bin der meinung man könnte
auch alle biologisch ernähren
wir müssen uns gedanken darüber machen
dass wir auch wirklich alles was wächst
bei uns auch verbrauchen dass wir beim
hähnchen zum beispiel nicht nur brust
sondern auch für keule und das gerüst
nutzen und nicht nach afrika bringen
oder schweine füße nach china 300 rinder
und schweine hält stolze sowie 2500
masthähnchen ihr müsst kommt als dünger
auf die felder zu viel gülle wie bei der
massentierhaltung hat er nicht den
protest gegen das agrar paket der
bundesregierung kann er nur bedingt
nachvollziehen im großen und ganzen ist
mir auch die bereitschaft in der
landwirtschaft zur veränderung zu gering
sind einfach das geht nicht und
veränderungen will man immer nicht
durchziehen
zum beispiel beim reizthema glyphosat
bauer stolze entfernt unkraut mechanisch
glyphosat ist ein totaler her bezieht
das muss man erst mal klar sein dass das
bedeutet ich spritze es aus und damit
wird sämtliche pflanze die zu dem
zeitpunkt grün ist platz auf dem acker
hat getötet weil schädlingen setzt
stolze ebenfalls auf schonendere bio
mittel braucht man dann in kauf nimmt
dass nicht jedes gemüse reif ist für den
schönheitswettbewerb
sein fleisch ist etwa 20 prozent teurer
als konventionelles so kann er von
seinem betrieb leben sagt er und das
könnten auch andere land wenn wir aber
bei 100 prozent bio wären dann hätten
wir in meinen augen genug nahrungsmittel
für alle in deutschland und nicht zum
zum exportierenden dann werden wir
wieder beim fairen preisen und dann
könnten alle davon leben zumindest so
der landwirt während 100 prozent bio
besser fürs tirol und besser für die
umwelt
ja das klingt toll an die kaders ist
gelernte landwirt und lockt unter
erklärt baur de über ihren beruf klärt
auf auch auf instagram aktiv wie siehst
du das denn ist bio landwirtschaft jetzt
die lösung und der heilsbringer
ich liebe ja die diskussion bio und
konventionell deswegen musste ich gerade
schon grinsen also klar letztendlich ist
irgendwann der markt an bio produkten
auch gesättigt wenn jetzt alle auf bio
umsteigen
dann haben haben wir auch nicht
gleichzeitig 100 prozent käufer auf der
anderen seite und außerdem ist der markt
dann auch irgendwann voll also ob das so
funktioniert so einfach glaube ich nicht
aber ich bin da auch immer für diesen
mittelweg offen also für mich ist der
favorit immer so im endeffekt haben
beide ihre positiven eigenschaften und
wenn man das wirklich vermischt und
daraus einen mittleren weg geht dann
wenn ich damit er zufrieden und findet
dass zukunftsfähige als ich für bio oder
konventionell entscheiden was ist denn
der mittelweg zwischen ich bringe keine
insektizide aufs feld auf oder ich
spritze damit nichts mehr wächst
na ja keine insektizide ausbringen und
spritzen damit nichts mehr weg dahin
werden ein insektizid und einem herbizid
das sind ja schon mal zwei unterschiede
aber okay so wie du hast du mich
erwischt der biobetrieb positive
eigenschaften positive arbeitsweisen hat
und auf der anderen seite mit der
konventionellen betrieb auch und wir
haben viele betriebe wie zum beispiel
michael reber mit dem bin ich viel in
kontakt der nachhaltige landwirtschaft
beziehungsweise regenerative
landwirtschaft ins spiel gebracht hat
das ist ein bisschen ein mythos beiden
und vor allen dingen ist bei allen drei
die grundlage der boden und darauf muss
man aufbauen und wenn man sich da
wirklich aus einem werkzeug tool
verschiedene sachen bedienen kann und
daraus dann für sich und für das know
how das land wird ist die beste den
besten weg einschlagen kann finde ich
das persönlich zukunftsweisend also
letztendlich der landwirt so wie ich
jetzt zum beispiel auch ab 5 jahre
ausbildung hinter mir also ausbildung
und studieninhalte und ich kann das ja
ganz anders einschätzen ganz anders
beleuchten und wenn am ende auch der
praktiker der das umsetzen muss und wenn
ich dann rein aus der theorie dinge
vorgeschlagen oder vor gesagt bekomme
dann funktioniert das nach einer
behandlung durch deswegen bio oder
konventionell ist immer so eine riesen
diskussion aber wie gesagt ich finde ein
mittlerer weg sollte auch noch offen
sein und wenn wir richtungen tierwohl
label gehen oder richtung rhein bio
wirtschaft in deutschland dann haben wir
halt keine möglichkeiten mehr diese
vielfalt auszuleben die wir aktuell noch
haben ich habe mir meinen kommentar
passt tatsächlich dazu von klima auf
youtube der sie schreibt fleisch sollte
man generell nicht importieren dürfen
wie kann es sein dass fleisch aus
südamerika um die halbe welt reist und
billiger ist als bio fleisch aus
deutschland
das ist ja schon eine frage die man sich
stellen muss sowohl marktwirtschaftlich
aber auch als verbraucher was kauft man
also wenn ich dich richtig verstehe
sagst du es gibt ein biomarkt bereich
oder segment das ist irgendwann
gesättigt weil nicht alle bereit sind so
viel geld auszugeben aber ist das nicht
vielleicht auch eher das problem das man
leuten erklären sorry wenn du eine gute
punkte kaufen möchte dass der es gut
gegangen ist ich habe heute noch
nachgeguckt die die ich gekauft habe hat
das kostet 32 euro das kilo
das ist halt schon ein ordentlicher
preis da muss man halt sagen okay ich es
halt weniger fleisch und kann dann so
eine nachhaltige landwirtschaft
befördern
absolut also klar muss ich auf der seite
des einkaufes auch was tun also wie du
schon sagst die bereitschaft dafür mehr
geld auszugeben und eine nachhaltige
produktionsweise zu vergüten muss
definitiv da sein also ich hab zb in
münster jetzt nur direkt
vermarktungsplattform aufgebaut
da ist nämlich dieser mittlere weg das
heißt unser siegel ist der landwirt
selber der stellt sich vor das stellt
sein betrieb transparent vor und
vermarktet sein eigenes produkt und das
ist hier in der region gerade für mich
ein pilotprojekt und dass wir dabei auch
angenommen und das ist also in das geht
eher in die richtung also man muss quasi
den verbraucher der muss der muss sich
an die nase packen also jeder muss sich
an die nase packen weil schließlich sind
wir alle verbraucher aber auf der
anderen seite muss man auch dann mit dem
landwirt gemeinsam an lösungen arbeiten
und nicht einfach nur vorgeben sondern
wirklich gemeinsam und miteinander
genau auf diese idee die duh gehabt das
wollte ich gerade kommen ich gebe mal
deine seite 1 die heißt bauern box.de
com sorry jetzt habe ich mich schon
vertippt bauern und kam vox dotcom da
kann man quasi das leben die
lebensmittel zu stellen die man haben
möchte vom bauern in die stadt schreibst
du hier und das ganze muss man dann hier
bestellen kann man sagen was mich die
haben produkte gleich zum beispiel kann
man bier knacker kaufen da habe ich
sofort lust bekommen bier und wurst
wie bist du auf diese idee gekommen und
wieso glaubst du dass menschen das
lieber so machen als das einfach im
supermarkt zu laufen und zu sagen ich
weiß alles in korb und geh nach hause
weil ich mich da viel mehr mit dem
lebensmittel auseinander setzen muss wie
bin ich darauf gekommen
ich selber wollte gerne wissen woher
meine lebensmittel komme ich komm ja
auch nicht direkt vom land also ich bin
ja auch externen die landwirtschaft
reingekommen und habe im supermarkt
tatsächlich nicht mehr den bezug zum
lebensmittel gehabt und auch nicht
gefunden das heißt wenn man das umdrehte
und das ist vielleicht die molkerei die
bei der milch hinten drauf steht aber
nicht wirklich wo die milch herkommt und
wie der landwirt beziehungsweise der
landwirtschaftliche betrieb dahinter
eigentlich aufgestellt ist und genau da
wollte ich mehr transparenz schaffen und
es gibt schon einige angebote der
direktvermarkter und dann ist es aber
auf der einen seite ziemlich
intensiv wirklich alles abzuklappern
sich das anzugucken und seinen
einkaufskorb zu füllen und somit habe
ich gesagt im endeffekt direkt
direktvermarktung 2.0
wir bringen die sachen zu euch bzw der
landwirt bringt das in einer box zu euch
und der mittlerweile 16
landwirte die in der box mit machen die
wirklich hier um münster produzieren
maximal 50 kilometer denn das heißt für
mich regionalität und somit hat der
kunde auf der anderen seite halt auch
nicht die auswahl das heißt er hat nicht
die wahl
das argentinische rindfleisch zu kaufen
sondern bei uns gibt es nur das
rindfleisch was maximal 50 kilometer in
münster erzeugt wurde und bei uns gibt
es auch mit das was gerade wächst und
nicht bananen oder ananas weiter weg
nicht dass ich sagen möchte man darf das
nicht essen
ich bin auch ein mensch der nicht 100
prozent auf alles verzichten möchte aber
nichtsdestotrotz gibt das auch
gleichzeitig ein anreiz wirklich zu
wissen was ist was wächst in meiner
region was habe ich hier zur verfügung
und kann mich so dann auch regional und
saisonal ernährung ist denn das was was
du glaubst was man tatsächlich auf ganz
deutschland ausdehnen kann also das
stelle ich mir jetzt auch wieder
schwierig vor das er braucht ein großes
netzwerk viele bauern haben feste
verträge mit abnehmern mit großen
lebensmittelketten oder mit großen
nahrungsmittelherstellern die ihnen dann
gleich 50 tonnen abkaufen und dann ist
der drops gelutscht warum sollten die
jetzt quasi versuchen ihre sachen
klein-klein zu verkaufen was haben sie
davon ist es überhaupt wirtschaftlich
für die also wirtschaftlich ist es ist
natürlich ein riesenthema und auch
aktuell ein schwieriges thema weil wir
schon gesagt hast der großabnehmer nimmt
eine große menge ab ich als kleines
start-up direktvermarktung online kann
aktuell noch nicht viel abnehmen nur das
was wirklich auch die kunden nachfragen
das ist natürlich für den einen für den
landwirt auch ein risiko damit
einzusteigen auf der anderen seite ist
das auch ein punkt öffentlichkeitsarbeit
und die der direkte kontakt zu dem
endkunden ist so so wertvoll man bekommt
direkt rückmeldung was kann ich anders
machen was kann nicht verbessern ist
mein produkt gut und dieses lob dass das
produkt auch gut ist das kommt bei dem
landwirt vom handel aus ja gar nicht
mehr an das heißt wenn im supermarkt und
die milch gekauft wird dann wird der
landwirt am ende ja nicht hätte eine
milch versuch weil der teilweise ja gar
nicht wissen wo sie wirklich herkommt
und bei mir ist es so dass die landwirte
den direkten kontakt
dem endkunden haben was für die die
wirklich sehr sehr wertvoll ist und auf
der anderen seite aber für meine kunden
auch sehr wertvoll ist weil er wieder
viel näher an die landwirtschaft
rankommt die produktions art und weise
versteht und auch für sich frei
entscheiden kann nehme ich das produkt
oder nämlich nicht ich gucke mal in die
kommentare was hier so drin steht ob du
auf deine initiative einen kommentar
kommt
ich sehe noch keinen darf man hasst du
jemanden hast du einen gefunden der
direkt auf das konzept eingeht noch
nicht dann frage ich nochmal nach annika
das ding jetzt super für kleine
regionale bauern aber wir haben ja auch
betriebe gerade in ostdeutschland die
sind riesig 1000 hektar und mehr
manche gehören schon agrarkonzernen die
erwischt oder mit nicht mit dem konzept
also ich will auch gar nicht alle damit
erreichen letztendlich ist das auch eine
nische so wie ich gerade gesagt habe bio
ist eine nische die irgendwann den markt
auch voll hat ob es erweitert sich die
mission definitiv gerade aber so ist
mein mein konzept auch eine nische das
heißt wenn nicht jeder landwirt es dafür
gemacht also ich hab da auch genaue
kriterien ich arbeite auf diesen
betrieben mit ich gucke mir die genau an
wir wirtschaften die welche statements
haben die zu meinen fragen nach welche
philosophie arbeiten die über
schließlich gebe ich das ja nach an den
konsumenten weiter und er vertraut mir
ja dass ich das geschafft habe mit
meinem land wirtschaftlichen know how
deswegen ist das gar nicht möglich für
alle so zu machen
aber rein regional ist das schon aus
weiter in deutschland dh wir haben jetzt
hier münster darum haben wir die 50
kilometer
wir können das aber auch in einer
anderen stadt realisieren drumherum die
landwirte einspannt und das direkt in
die in die stadt bringe schließlich gibt
es direkt vermarktung auch in ganz
deutschland und von daher denke ich
jetzt dass auf jeden fall skalierbar für
deutschland und ich war letzte vor zwei
wochen sogar noch in brasilien durfte
mich mit verschiedenen ländern
austauschen und selbst da wurde das
konzept auch über deutschland hinaus
angenommen und ist wahrscheinlich auch
realisierbar so war das feedback das ok
du ich guck doch mal in die kommentare
und hab mir nochmal zwei die ich mit in
die bütt schmeißen möchte einmal griffel
auf periscope schreibt wir sind auch zu
geizig drei euro pro kilo fleisch mehr
zu zahlen
bei uns zählt nur noch billig anstatt
qualität und gereon auf facebook meint
wer billige produkte will es eben nicht
derjenige der verstanden hat dass er
damit nachhaltig die umwelt zerstört für
diesen wunsch durch sein handeln als
bauer befördert hat ebenfalls nicht
verstanden dass der teil dieser
zerstörungs maschinerie ist das geht so
ein bisschen in die richtung was du auch
sagt im endeffekt müssen wir alle
anpacken damit sich was ändert
definitiv jeder jeder muss sich quasi an
die eigene nase packen und sie
hinterfragen was uns ja ganz schwer
fällt schließlich haben wir immer unsere
gewohnten strukturen aber da müssen wir
jetzt aber wirklich hinterfragen was
schließlich mit jedem einkauf
entscheiden wir auch wofür
beziehungsweise was dahinter steckt und
wie die zukunft aussieht und das sollten
wir uns halt auch jedes mal bewusst
machen
beim einkauf von b auch bei dem bei dem
essen selber weil das durch die zeit die
wir immer weniger haben einfach
verschwindet was das bewusstsein für das
lebensmittel an sich angeht
und ich war zum beispiel letztes jahr
auf notschlepper gerade haben auch viele
mit denen wir im interview standen
gesagt dass tatsächlich sie selber
einfach keine wahl fühlen wenn sie im
supermarkt stehen und sie haben fünf
produkte vor sich dann greifen sie zu
dem günstigsten weil einfach
psychologisch gesehen für sie dann der
drang nach dem günstigsten da ist weil
es ist ja schließlich vorhanden und dann
kann sie können sie es auch kaufen und
diesen gedanken kann ich schon gut
nachvollziehen weil ja letztendlich
bleibt dann auch mehr in seinem eigenen
portemonnaie und wenn jeder sich an die
nase fassen ist quasi jedem soweit
geholfen also das ja da kann ich die
entscheidung schon verstehen aber man
sollte auf jeden fall darüber nachdenken
weil letztendlich löst man dann wird
halt auch genau das aus wo wir aktuell
stehen beziehungsweise entscheidet damit
auch wo wir hingehen
also im endeffekt müssen wir alle
überlegen was wir am besten tun können
die politik ist aber auch gefordert und
da scheint das noch viel redebedarf zu
geben wie wir heute gesehen haben in
berlin bei der demo annika vielen dank
dass du heute abend für uns da war es
schöne grüße in den kuhstall und euch
auch vielen dank für eure kommentare und
fürs zu sehen wir sehen uns das nächste
mal am donnerstag wieder hier im
livestream bis dahin sage ich mach's gut
und tschüss und wenn euch der leitstelle
gefallen habe dann guck doch mal hier da
gibt es einen mit einem koch der alles
vom tier zu lecker essen verarbeitet
oder hier gibt es ein gespräch mit
harald lesch und
kollegen über das klima paket der
bundesregierung der sich auch nicht
aufgeregt wenn er schon mal hier seid
lasst noch ein like und einen kommentar
und ein abo da